- Well, I'm gonna start with-
- Look her all grown.
I'm gonna start calling you Ms. Ferguson.
- [Kelly] I know.
She looks so nice in the code
and everything it's cute.
Happy late birthday!
- Thank you.
- Happy birthday!
- That's so exciting!
What did you, did you throw three parties
for your sweet sixteen?
- No, I threw one party and last weekend
on my actual birthday I went to the fair.
- Oh, that's fun.
Did you get any good gifts?
- Um, I got a lot of good gifts actually.
I think the biggest gift that
I got was throwing a party
because I was not only celebrating just me
but my friends as well, and my family.
So that was, it was really fun.
- That's nice.
- [Kelly] That's nice!
- That's a good heart.
You know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Thoughtful, yeah.
- I did that with my friends.
We, we all turned 50 this
year, so I took everybody
out to Columbia and we celebrated,
I celebrated their 50th
with them and that was
one of my celebrations.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's cool.
So we were playing a game
before you got out here
and I was just wondering what you thought
if you were gonna rate this guy, how,
how would you rate this guy's look?
- Oh, if you want it
bigger, it's right here.
It's really beautiful
and like big right here.
- That's very centric.
(Kelly laughing)
I like-
- That's a nice way of
saying that's a bad outfit.
- [Kelly] That's centric!
- It look like my grandma
sewed up my scarf and my hat.
- Oh my god.
Remember when those
hats were so big though?
I had 'em too.
I wore them everywhere.
I love those hats.
- It Threw, I threw it together
well though, I thought.
(Kelly laughing)
- Yeah, for his time it was-
- [Kelly] For his time!
(Kelly laughing)
- No, I'm not saying I'm
not saying it in a bad way!
- I love it!
No, it's not ever a good way.
It was great.
- Yeah.
- That's the response I wanted.
So wait, so you are so
great in the new movie.
I love the movie.
I was telling him I love,
literally my kids loved it so much.
They sent it to us earlier
and we watched it like three times.
- [Marlon] Oh, good.
- My kids loved it.
- [Marlon] Thank you.
- Um and I thought,
I kept thinking maybe they might be scared
at certain things, like the
the red thing, like punk vibe.
- Mm-hmm
- I was like, maybe, but nope.
So when did you, when did
you know you wanted to act?
Cause you're so young.
- Um, I've always had
like a big personality
ever since I was younger.
Like everywhere I would go,
I would just make
conversation with people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I did impersonations
as well when I was younger.
I would impersonate Wendy Williams,
when her first show came out.
I would walk around in my mom's blonde wig
and I would impersonate her.
And I was also into a lot
of movies that had a lot
of drama to them, and suspense.
So I guess a mixture of
all those things kind
of drew me to acting and...
- I love that.
It was a really, really great film.
I love y'all's chemistry.
- [Marlon] Thank you.
- [Kelly] It was so fun.
- It was funny cause I thought she knew I,
I knew her work from Stranger Things,
and I just loved, you know it was
like her sassy little attitude.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She always had something
to say and I thought
for a father to have to deal
with that big personality
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- and understand that it's not wrong.
She's just expressing herself
and you have to understand
this youth and this culture.
And I thought she knew my work.
This girl ain't know none of my work.
- I did know your work!
- I said, "How you not see White Chicks?
What is wrong with you, child?"
(Kelly laughing)
- I watched the scary movies!
- So you've, you've also started
your own production company
right?
- [Priah] Mm-hmm
- So you're, let me
remind you again. Sixteen.
That's incredible.
So what, why, what was the purpose?
Why do you want to have this company?
What do you wanna do with it?
- Um, the purpose of the
production company was
to center young girls of color
and young black girls in movies
and in shows as well.
And not only is it a production company,
but it's a creative company as well.
So not only are we producing
but we're doing other things as well, so.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
- [Marlon] That's really good.
- Yeah.
- And, I know it's centered
around young black girls,
but how about old black men?
If you got something for
me, you know what I mean?
(Kelly laughing)
- I'll let you know. I'll let you know.
- Does that make you proud though?
Like somebody you're working with?
She's so young and starting off so young
and thinking about more than herself
and like trying to make the
industry more inclusive.
That's pretty cool.
- You know, I, I've been writing
and producing movies
since I was like nineteen.
I first came in the industry,
and to see that makes my heart warm
because normally I have to sit down
and school kids, even my own children,
and tell them you have to be proactive.
You have to generate
projects for yourself.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And for her at sixteen to know that
and to begin that process I
think is, is, is wonderful.
You know, I'm, I've been
in the game now thirty,
thirty years and it's only
because I've been writing, producing,
and acting, and creating projects
for myself and others
since I was nineteen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
That's awesome though.
You do generate your own material.
Like sometimes you have to do that
cause it's not there what you wanna-
- Yeah, you have to.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I wanted to say this
too about the movie.
I, I loved how relatable
it was for a lot of us.
Like, you know, how the
dad like how you kind
of played your role
and you weren't understanding
and like, you were trying
to help him understand you.
And like, I don't like
science as much as you.
Like, but how then you
incorporated it was really cute.
I just thought the family
dynamic was really cool too.
- Thank you. You really watched the movie.
You watched watched.
- I did, I did.
- Sometime you come to the
show. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw the movie. It was great.
- No, I, I'm not kidding.
I've seen it more than once.
My son specifically,
six year old loves it.
- Wow. So it's gonna be on Netflix, y'all.
Curse of Bridge Hollow!
- [Kelly] He loved it. He loved it.
He loved the giant spider like
attacking and getting you all
and he was like, she should
have just left him there.
(Marlon laughing)
That's who my son is.
So what was the best thing
about working with Marlon?
- The best thing about
working with Marlon,
I mean it was a lot of
things we bonded so well
and he gave me like a lot
of advice on set especially.
And our chemistry was really great.
- It was.
- Just seeing him play a dad
in a movie was also cool to me
cause when I watched a few of his movies,
I don't think I
really remember seeing
him actually play, a dad.
- She's like there's no way somebody gonna
have kids with him.
(all laughing)
- So that was really fun to see.
- I know, it was really good.
Your chemistry.
That matters, like the
casting and you know
that really matters
and we're watching we
can I'm not an actor,
but I it's transparent
whenever you can see it
like clicking or if it's
not, it was really good.
- Yeah.
I loved it.
- She's a, a joy to work with.
A lot of fun.
Very sweet.
And you know, and it
was fun to have someone
that you could like teach
things and you know, listen
and you know, I looked at,
cause I love, my children so
having her was like having,
being around my kids and if she come in
and I see that she's
not having a good day,
I'm like "Alright, what's bothering you?".
"There's this girl at school."
- [Kelly] That happens.
- And then I would give,
give her some bad advice
(Kelly laughing)
and well but that, that helped
us bond because at the end
of the day
you have to realize that's a young person
and you have to bring
yourself back to youth
and understand that, you know,
they have life outside a movie.
So let's, before we start this day,
let's talk about what's bothering you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We did that and-
- That's pretty cool. That's
probably why it came across
on camera, so well. That's awesome!